he says it's only fair to make sure
they're all there
so should we check our politicians for
diminished cognitions
louisiana senator they have them there
cat bill cassidy says elderly members of
all three branches of government should
undergo regular cognition tests before
the rapid decline in their 80s oof
cassidy who's a gastroenterologist who
isn't am i right
didn't single anyone out in particular
but the message was clear
medicine lets us live longer and lead
the country at 78 or 81 what concerns do
you have about that it's usually
noticeable
so
anybody in a position of responsibility
who may potentially be on that slope
that is of concern and i'm saying this
is a doctor i'm told that there have
been senators in the past who at the end
of their senate term were sino
i'm told that was true of senators of
both parties we each have a sacred
responsibility to the people of the
united states it is not about me it is
about my ability to serve the people and
if you thought their cognitive scores
were low check out their numbers in the
40-yard dash
pathetic okay so let's acknowledge the
obvious our country's leaders are
elderly biden's 78 pelosi's she's 81 but
her face is 57.
[Laughter]
senate president pat leahy is also 81
house majority leader steny hoyer is 82
senator chuck grassley 88. they're
almost old enough to star in the sex and
the city reboot
and aoc is 32 very young but we're
including her because she's nuts
and three current supreme court justices
are over 70. alito thomas and pryor
who's 83 they'd get a lot more done if
they didn't constantly have to urinate
tell me about it now regardless of
performance it's a fair question to ask
why do our politicians never know when
to leave like andrew cuomo after that
time he got a lot of people killed you
think you'd get the message
the average retirement age is in this
country is 63. so many politicians are
way past that now this is not to say all
of our political problems are due to
senility senility doesn't explain this
wow
what do you want to know yeah
doesn't explain this
and it doesn't explain this the evidence
is uncontradicted that the president
used taxpayer dollars to ask the
ukrainians to help them cheat an
election
anybody could break wind at any time
katie doesn't ha
farting knows no age you would know
craig
oh that was unnecessary you know um why
is it so hard for politicians to know
when to leave well greg let me tell you
something about washington dc
it's a place that's run by a bunch of
drunk 20 year olds who work for a bunch
of elderly folks and then in the middle
there's like a bunch of sociopaths or
people like
eric swalwell who want to be a drunk 20
year old again but somehow found himself
elected in an office and responsible for
things so that explains a lot about
what's going on in terms of the sinality
test sure but people like chuck grassley
for example he runs like five miles
every morning so he could probably beat
nancy pelosi right so i think it's good
to have if you're gonna have a threshold
for running for office maybe you can
have one for leaving office but you
shouldn't be dying on the floor of the
senate like it's not a morgue or a
mortuary it's the u.s senate have some
respect
it's pretty funny though i mean like
after all this talk about how we need
new blood cat it's still the same old
blood exactly even if we tested them
it's not like they would leave
hey look you know it turns out you're
senile they're like oh oh man well thank
you for the opportunity it's been great
serving my country i'll pack my things
no
they never pack their things dying is
really the only way out no matter what
you say once you give them the power
they will hold it until they die and i
can understand that in some extent it's
not like i've ever had any power
so i don't know what i would do with it
yeah it's scary i don't think you should
ever have any power cat
i think we should try like my ideas like
might be crazy but at least we'd be
having fun yes we would sort of now when
we're not having fun that is true what
do you uh why is it that they i i you
know
why don't they take the hint and go
because they're in positions of power
it's like cat was saying and that's fun
and they never want to let it go what
you need is an embarrassment factor
right this is why i say everyone has to
take the test we don't tell them when
the test is coming it's mental and
physical just one day somebody gets them
in the neck with a blow dart and they
wake up
it'll
it'll be like the squid games right yeah
they just wake up in a warehouse wearing
a green track suit and then
like with joe biden you have to ask him
questions like you'd ask a three year
old do i or do i not now have your nose
[Laughter]
that got me every time
right when he reaches oh no all right
you gotta go you gotta go yeah now we
show the whole thing on tv but it's
pay-per-view greg
people will shell out 90 bucks a pop to
watch you retire the national debt boom
right yeah great idea do they leave
office i don't think so welcome to the
idea why would you leave a job where you
don't have to do anything
and you get paid
right right you know you get to write it
trains all day if you want if you're joe
biden it's like i want to be a senator
after seeing that segment yeah you know
by the way they get so much free stuff
and other stuff really they have a free
haircut yes down at the can you imagine
how much that saves when you're 900
years old and you haven't paid for a
haircut you can pound that savings
you're rich you could buy like you could
buy like a another home for bernie
sanders i i you know you're so old he
was also old but he's kind of still
cogent correct he had bad ideas from the
beginning but they're the same bad ideas
right and everyone respects you yes yeah
no it's just hanging around i have to
earn respect i still haven't figured out
how to do that
the gerontocracy i think is one of the
reasons why people are so angry
especially if you're under 60 you're
like i've got nowhere to go yes i'm
stuck in the mail room of america
that is it that's like and under 60.
we're not talking about like oh you know
eric weinstein talks about that a lot
it's like like you can't clear the brush
that's in front of you and so
everybody's kind of stuck in the same
spot very interesting just imagine
bernie sanders in a green tracksuit him
to play that hand game
oh that's entertainment all right enough
out of you gene jacket guy hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else